RAF scampton was once a piece of
Britain's military heritage
a former home of the red arrows and
before that the Dam Busters fabled
Squadron who carried out a famous second
world war airing
now this used this Airfield is at the
heart of our modern migration debate
with government plans to turn it into
temporary accommodation for Asylum
Seekers that's uh the accommodation
blocks Sarah and Paul who live a stone's
Railway are concerned RAF scampton is
probably the most famous Air Force Base
there is you know it was a dambuster
trade it'll be an actual sacrilege to to
lose all that and we will lose all that
you know they're getting to say oh well
it's only temporary but temporary what's
temporary there's no infrastructure here
for them so the conditions that they're
going to be living in are inhumane The
Local District Council had put in place
this 300 million pound plan to protect
the site's Heritage and drive investment
the local MP knows it's a bloatal
efforts to level up the area but feels
unable to stop the home office there are
a hundred buildings on that side all of
which will deteriorate over the two or
three years that are there so we're not
resigned to it we're completely opposed
but I've just got to accept that legal
Lee the council cannot stop it
historians saved this can't be stopped
the plan threatens not just the past but
scampton's future too this is about a
choice for the future of an incredibly
Rich historical uh setting within the
United Kingdom we're not saying don't
put refugees somewhere we're saying
don't put them on scampton
at the heart of this proposal a people
Asylum Seekers who want to live in
acceptable condition moving to a new
place and coming from a war zone you're
you're hoping for this new place to be
your new home so you need to interact
with people
see how people live so if it's like far
away from these kind of like daily
interactions and having the sense of
community then it's going to affect them
in a in a really
even more traumatizing way the
government says the pressure on the
Asylum system is unprecedented
and it is committed to engaging with
local authorities and key stakeholders
but in a place used to spectacular
takeoffs this plan has caused a debate
that shows no sign of ending soon
and Lincolnshire